[Applause]
anything else from chapelle and uh the
special seems like the outrage continues
it seems like
i don't want to speak too soon but it
seems like
this might be the tipping point yes it
seems like the executives might have
realized that they could push back
and there will be more support in their
pushback than there will be in their
cancellation and i think i think
chappelle
is an example of someone who's
too big to fail right in other words
like at the end of the day like these
people are capitalists right they're not
moralists they're capitalists right so
as they should be they exist in a
capitalist country and uh when we're
talking about like saying words and
saying jokes
you're not listen i'm not gonna define
like how you're actually hurting
somebody but you're not basically saying
you you're not equal to other people
right right
it's being spoken about is different
than treating someone actually
differently in terms of like the law
like if if the head of netflix came out
and said like yeah we just don't do any
trans shows on this platform that would
be wrong right but if the head of
netflix is like hey we have jokes about
black people we have jokes about jews we
have jokes about puerto ricans we have
jokes about asians everybody gets joked
about on this platform including trans
there is more consistency even if you're
outraged all of those groups can also be
outrageous right but he is big enough
yeah where it's worth the scrutiny yes
and
maybe that's unfortunate for like a
younger comic coming up but the same
time you get to look at it and you go oh
[ __ ] there's a tipping point yeah i can
get successful enough to say what the
[ __ ] i had the exact same feeling and i
i said this i didn't think in the same
terms of pure capitalism but i said this
when chappelle did sticks and stones to
be honest is my least favorite of the
six netflix specials but it knew it was
really important that that guy was going
at cancel culture yeah we can be
forerunners of flagrancy and all of that
but chappelle is the guy that has enough
cultural currency where if he fights
back against it the silent majority
feels a little bit more like being like
yeah yeah i can now they can get a
little louder and say yo
chappelle's funny you can act like he's
offensive but i don't give a [ __ ] he's
funny and i'm very confident saying
chappelle is funny and y'all are wrong
and once he started doing that and
leaned in and didn't back off
i think you heard every dude i remember
bossa posted something a week ago about
it and the comments in boston tend to be
pretty liberal but they were like yo the
special is funny these guys need to just
let it go funny is funny and that is
where i think i was like yeah this is
the tipping point this is the guy that
needed to do it yeah yeah i think it's
like
i don't know there's just there's
something to having that
currency having that
value as an entertainer where you have
earned the right to get away with these
things because the corporations don't uh
take any loss yeah you know it's similar
to
being a feature on the road like let's
say you're featuring for somebody in
stand-up right
you can say whatever you want to say
when you go on stage right before that
headliner and you can say whatever you
you go on stage uh you know when you're
performing that club for the first time
but your goal is to continue performing
at the club right now you can beat a
hard ass you can choose to go i'm going
to say whatever the [ __ ] i want i don't
care if these venues let me play etc and
then you might not get any stage time
and it might be harder for you to
develop your act etc
but you can also choose to play by the
rules
that the venue is imposed on you or the
headliner has imposed on you right and
then learn how to succeed within those
rules and build up your audience build
up your your leverage to the point where
you can make a chapel type situation
where you can get away with whatever you
want yes and
look we found different ways around it
when we were starting out what we
basically said is well we're going to
produce our own shows producing your own
show is like being your own netflix yes
a microcosm of it but you can't get
cancelled from your own show way less
subscribers to our patreon than netflix
but it's ours yes we can't fire
ourselves from it yes i mean i guess
patreon could do something but what i
mean like live stand-up shows yeah but
if you're willing to play within the
system that's something that you're
gonna have to negotiate with and see how
much clout you could build up and what
you can get away with you know and also
this is again hammering my point home
defending chappelle as a human being
doesn't require much bravery if you want
to defend me who nobody really like
people don't really know like that you
got to be real [ __ ] sure i'm funny
but you can very confidently as just a
fan be like nah chappelle is funny y'all
are wrong defending a guy that's kind of
obscure or whatever doesn't have nearly
the spotlight it just takes a lot more
strength for a common person to even
tweet nah chappelle is funny these guys
are wrong it's also the perfect group to
pick to be canceled for
because the majority of people truly
don't understand trans
so
people do understand gay even if they
don't like it they understand it right
they empathize with it they have an
uncle that's gay they have a cousin
that's gay they have a friend that's gay
there's something about homosexuality
that's just way more understandable
they've seen characters in their
favorite tv shows that are gay they
understand it you probably have a gay
family member yeah that's what i was
saying i don't know yeah
yeah um so so there it's just way more
digestible homosexuality so when you're
saying something that the gay community
is offering pushback for
all of a sudden you start thinking about
that human being that you know and love
yes right
trans is so foreign to the average
person right like i know mark you said
you have a trans friend but like anybody
else here have not only transferred like
a trans person in any way in their life
yep
who
mark's friend that he just said that he
knows
someone that you personally interact
with
literally the person that serves you
coffee at your favorite diner yeah no
not at all it is such a small part of
the population that occupy such a large
part of the conversation right because
i'm sure it's thrown into this culture
war a little bit but it's the perfect
group that if you have to get canceled
for something because the majority of
people we're not talking about industry
the majority of people have no [ __ ]
clue what the trans thing is so they're
kind of like i don't really care what
you say it's like getting canceled for
like the hmong chinese population it's
like how many is that exactly so so now
if you're a network executive like hold
on i'm gonna cancel the biggest comedian
for a group of people that don't even
got a netflix account like yeah
yeah i mean like i don't
0.1 of netflix accounts are from this
community i'm gonna cancel my biggest
comic for that yeah i'm a capitalist
right and that don't make no [ __ ]
sense yeah yeah so it is the perfect
group to beef with like if you want to
die on a horse of racism you won't be
dead yeah yeah you know what i mean you
want to die in a horse of homophobia
you're going to be dead you want to die
the horse of uh
of like some sort of religious
uh bigotry yeah you don't mean like
attacking christians or something like
that like christians are a little bit
easier to to go after but still you have
a large percent of the country going
whoa whoa whoa whoa really any religion
you go after islam i mean he attacked
jews yeah well he attacked israel not
and he barely didn't
like he just
he just a couple of jokes nothing crazy
yeah if he said what he said about
jewish people about trans people oh yeah
it's over oh yeah he made the whole
special he's just about the
israel-palestine situation like he did
about the trans thing gotcha oh we're
gonna have yeah we're gonna have a
conversation all right guys we're gonna
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip you can find the whole episode at
patreon.com flagrant2 though but i got
to tell you about the best underwear in
the business this clip is provided to
you guys by culprit culprit is the best
underwear in the business now they give
me all these facts about their micro
modal or whatever the [ __ ] that means
they're made in america the best
products and use very little water and
all this other stuff you know what they
are they're the most comfortable
underwear you'll ever wear in your life
once i started wearing them i haven't
worn another pair of underwear since i
swear to god what are you wearing right
now right now i got my culprits on dog
oh [ __ ]
oh you got the all black you know what
i'm saying i'm with the all blacks i
like them purples they actually got
great advertising there's a bunch of
really funny ones too they got a sense
of humor those [ __ ] okay they got a
sense of humor those [ __ ] over there
culprit but i'm telling you right now
you can go get your culprits and i
promise you i mean you dm me if i'm
wrong but i promise you that they will
be the best underwear you wear in your
life and you will not wear another pair
of underwear after that that is a fact
culpritunderwear.com use the promo code
flagrant you're going to get 20
off your order did you hear what i just
said 20 off your order when you go to
culpritunderwear.com use the promo code
flagrant for the best underwear you'll
ever wear in your life you'll never buy
a different brand again i promise you
now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip you can find the entire
episode at patreon.com flagrant2 thank
you all very much also a smart move for
him this is a testament to neil talking
about how good his brain is is to say
i'm not transphobic i just wish black
people had the same rights as trans
people so if you cancel dave chappelle
you kind of prove his point
if you pull him from netflix it's like
oh you're cancelling the black guy for
saying hey please give us the same
rights as trans people uh
now
it's a very clever positioning that's
the way i'm trying to award it yes
because he wins either way yeah his
point is proven if you cancel him yeah
and if he doesn't get cancelled then
awesome yeah i mean he says his
brilliant line where he says if you
think i'm transphobic you're not
listening or something like that yeah
yeah that was so good yeah i gotta use
it on my girl
yeah do you think i'm wrong you're not
listening to what i'm saying yeah yeah
like say even in the middle of a fight
like if you think i don't love you
you're not listening and she's like what
i mean it's a brilliant even though
i heard you say that i'm like yeah you
must love her
[Music]
i love you why are we arguing yeah yeah
why would we be disagreeing about how
much i love you and then she's like
we're not even [ __ ] talking about
love right now yeah
i guess
brilliant man such a simple s line just
get you like
good anything yeah because it makes you
question your own like am i an idiot did
i not care am i stupid maybe i'm not
listening and what he was saying was 100
transphobia yeah
that's the genius of it it was by
definition that's transphobic now you
know 90s i was like
by trans people's definition of
transphobia
it is vital book transphobic yes but
also by their definition
95 of people are transphobic yes because
95 of people are ignorant to what they
define transphobia as yeah yes 95 of
people just sitting here like
bro like i i don't get it yeah you're a
guy or you're a girl yeah that's all um
you know what i mean like we we do not
understand all this other [ __ ] yeah and
it gets cloudy with the
all the millions of different genders it
just keeps changing it feels like it
yeah they're not losing but you ever
play a game with like your cousin on
your kids and then he just keeps
switching the rules up to win
yeah that's kind of i think an
underlying emotion we have about like
what what is two spirits i wonder if
trans people like the og trans people
are kind of annoyed by all these like
new genders yeah because but they can't
say anything because they're fighting
for the same cause
so it's like you know how like gays were
kind of annoyed by trans when trans came
out yeah because they're like we got to
include them but god damn
just got this [ __ ] yeah like we come on
yo stop clowning it up where you been
this whole time right we got all the
rights now you here yeah and then the
trans maybe they feel the same way about
two spirit and all these other ones
because it's like they're they're out
here like listen gender
is fluid and then these other people
like oh yeah it is oh my god bro we just
want them to
accept the fact that i don't have a
penis but i think i'm a guy yeah
apparently there is beef have you heard
us do buck angel
yes the [ __ ] workout guy
workout trams yeah yeah like mustache oh
gee like trans person from like the 80s
the 90s yeah and like has all this beef
with like new trans people
because like he would just do [ __ ] that
was like yeah he would like call himself
a transvestite and he like did porn
because like he didn't really know where
to fit in the world he's like i feel
like a guy like so i guess what i would
say to trans people is like
the way y'all feel about the two spirits
yeah
most people feel about y'all
[Laughter]
right like so whatever emotion you got
when you hear someone saying i'm two
spirit and yeah i'm 69 i'm i'm asexual
i'm part whatever like when you look at
them and you go oh my god here we go
again that's unfortunately for you
how most people that just identify as
male or female view the trans community
yeah so have a little empathy yeah
because even though you truly feel what
you're going through is is real and it
is real to you i'm assuming it is real
to you
as ridiculous as these other things are
to you
you might be just that ridiculous to
somebody who just grew up and i'm gonna
throw this in quotes
normal
yeah
right yeah have some empathy absolutely
it's an easy position to have empathy
for which i think most people do it's
just like all the twitter [ __ ] like i
think again i think matter of fact there
was a trans comic on the show
that i performed with and i said and
they're mad cool he was mad cool i guess
the whole time and we're just talking
[ __ ] and then at the end he says
something i go yes ma'am and i'm like yo
my bad i didn't mean to and then he just
goes it's all good man it's fine i
appreciate you apologizing reach his
hand out and it's like oh if he took
that opportunity to shame me i'd have
been like yo [ __ ] these [ __ ]
dog but he was like hey school i
appreciate the apology i was like oh
okay oh it's a girl to guy girl the guy
if again if they took that high horse
opportunity to be like how dare you i'd
have been like hi [ __ ] can i not
just make a mistake yeah exactly how i
treat you it's like yeah it's all good
that's another thing i bet most trans
people are okay with the mistakes yeah
yeah yeah
that's how there's this comic that i
know that i'm friends with i'd like i
said guy it was guy a girl and i said
yeah what's up man or something like
that i was like oh my bad and she goes i
mean it's cool i didn't know i was a
girl until like two years anyway
yeah
i was like all right it took you 17
years to figure this out like yeah i'll
give you a few months like you'll figure
it out so like i don't know most people
i know i mean i only know one trend yeah
just my last question like when they got
a piss real bad yeah like if you're a
trans woman but you still got the
schmecks
you know when you got a p bad you like
rolling up to the urinal like you're
pulling your dick like you're a guy in
that situation right like yeah you can't
not be a guy like even the way you rip
your [ __ ] out real fast oh yeah like
there's nothing female about that moment
like when you're like pacing from side
to side like you pull your dick out like
a woman huh i don't know like more
delicately like with the fingers like
i'm saying you've got to go go are you
sitting down on the toilet or are you
whipping that [ __ ] out and you just
haven't whip it out femininely how just
with your finger like i don't know
if you got to pee you got to pee bro you
do it like that sounds like willow smith
like just whip your hair back and forth
just whip the dick out back and forth so
you can whip it out
you can pull women
you can pull your dick out like a lady
bro pinkies
but there's not you have to pee bad
yeah but just because you have a pb
doesn't mean you're not going to be a
woman in that moment
[Laughter]
we're not going to keep
but the whole trans community doesn't
even agree with itself because uh flame
monroe is a trans
woman but doesn't consider herself a
woman she doesn't identify as a woman
she says i'm a trans woman
no no she says i would never say i'm a
woman she says it's offensive to women
yeah she says i'm a trans woman oh yeah
yeah so it's like
even that it's like they're fighting
within their own community in terms of
every community black people gays like
asians like every community is fighting
amongst themselves like we can't look at
them as a monolith and that's what we
all go way newer too yeah they figure
[ __ ] out yeah they're still trying to
america didn't even america was like
everyone's equal
oh yeah
gotta make it happen yeah
yeah so it is what it is man i think
gays and lesbians are still trying to
figure that [ __ ] out
well that's the craziest thing is you
have this whole community the lgbtq plus
community and like i just know a bunch
of gay people are like yeah i don't [ __ ]
with the trans [ __ ] yeah
like really you know i just assumed you
guys were on the same page they're like
nah yeah
yeah yeah because they never had
anything more than them
and then trans are going to get some
[ __ ] more than them yeah and they're
going to go through the same thing yeah
that's what i was kind of saying earlier
like it just gets it just gets more and
more extreme you know what i mean like
you've heard about those like a body uh
dysmorphia people who feel like they
shouldn't have their leg so they get
their leg amputated yeah whoa and it's
illegal in some places but it should be
i've never heard that i mean should it
be but i was actually thinking about
your body
yeah no you're just making everybody's
life harder everybody
why you're not making anyone's life
yourself harder if you feel like your
finger's not yours and you get it
removed why shouldn't you first of all
you get the ill-ass parking spot that's
a good point if you do it just for a
parking spot that's [ __ ] up there's a
person that was born with no legs i
would love that parking spot probably
yeah second of all we gotta wheel your
dumbass around everywhere no you will
yourself
oh you ain't never helped a person in a
wheelchair no let's go finger just
finger off finger off all right it's
gotta be a line though you know what i
mean you can't do whole appendages you
want to lose a toe you got that well
that's the thing is like i was actually
thinking about this we think oh if you
get a body part moved you're [ __ ]
crazy you're insane but women get breast
reductions all the time all the time and
we go yeah they're just right they get
the [ __ ] uterus scooped out angelina
jolie got no [ __ ] hollow
angelia jolie hollow because she was
worried about getting i think she got
her [ __ ] no she got a brush chopped off
she got breast and her [ __ ] if you're
stealing her [ __ ]
vacuums
literally took the whole [ __ ] out
because she was worried about getting
ovarian cancer so she's trans no tits no
[ __ ] she's a dude that's a great point
that he's making right now
is it [ __ ] too what i don't think it's
[ __ ] too but if it is [ __ ] she's a
dude look it up she got ovarian she was
worried about getting ovarian cancer she
probably has some cysts you put your ear
up to her pelvis you just hear the ocean
you can hear it
if you put it put your nose if you can
smell it probably
so yeah i i just think look we're doing
it already we have those weirdos that
get the [ __ ] gauges in their ears and
[ __ ] you know someone to get their ears
snipped so they look like a tiger they
get their noses you get part of your
nose removed yeah that's better i hate
them too you know what's weird you add
something to your body and it's way more
understandable
like taking away is what's weird like if
you if you're a girl and you have
[ __ ] crippling back pain and you
reduce the size of your tits we're like
yo what is wrong like that's weird or
something like like you're out of like
what's happening right but if you get
huge breast implants that make your back
hurt people like say it there we go
there we go it's like surgery to make
your life easier makes sense surgery to
make your life harder doesn't yeah and
that's the equation we're trying to
solve
turning yourself into a trans woman or
trans male we look at we're like yo your
life is about to be tough yeah yeah you
were just a cis regular person and also
you're a
disenfranchised minority group you asked
for it
right even though you did it but like
we're looking like why would you do this
bro just like identify as a chick but
just dress normal so that your day is
okay right even though i understand it's
hard for them to do that that's the
outward perception of ease of course
because you look at a girl with big tits
and you go oh man your life must be so
easy but the back is killing her back's
killing her hates her life so walk that
[ __ ] off bro yeah maybe that's one way
of doing it but what about rods in your
back why can't you just if you're gonna
get something added you get like rods in
your back you'll last posture your whole
life yeah have great posture make your
back strong and then your titties can
hang freely
but maybe you can't bend over with the
rods in your back unimportant
yeah it is weird it is weird that what
we accept what we don't accept what up
people you just watch a clip from our
weekly patreon episode you can support
the flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic unfilled
uncensored content that we drop weekly
on our patreon at patreon.com flagrant2
you want to go join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace